[Music]
this is an artist painting a portrait of
a cat
she wasn't hired by this cat's owner but
by chewie
the online pet supply store the company
has sent out tens of thousands of these
surprise pet portraits over the past
eight years and during the pandemic
chewie customers have shared them across
social media
at the same time the company's business
has been booming
in 2020 chewie gained over five and a
half million
active customers we took action pretty
quickly actually in our opinion
and the strategy looking back was really
communicate
innovate and persevere here's how chewie
seized the pandemic pet craze
and ignited investor enthusiasm and why
some analysts think its success is built
to last
when the pandemic took hold in 2020
millions of people were forced to work
from home
and with more time on their hands they
adopted new pets
analysts estimate that more than 11
million pets found new homes during the
pandemic
and while pet owners were stuck at home
many turned to the internet to buy
supplies
according to a recent report consumers
bought 30 percent of their pet food and
supplies online last year
up from 23 in 2019 this added up to
about a five billion dollar increase in
online pet spending
lauren schenck who analyzes the pet
industry for morgan stanley
says this increase was a big benefit for
retailers
we do believe that the pet industry is
is better positioned than some other
e-commerce categories to retain
the gains that it saw in 2020 given the
sticky like nature of not only the
product
and pet food but also the customers
themselves which tend to be very loyal
to specific
retailers with the influx of new pet
owners
retailers like target and amazon all
gained more shoppers over the past year
but sitting at the top of the dog pile
chewy
morgan stanley says the company has the
number one market share position for
online pet retail
chewy has performed exceptionally well
during
the pandemic obviously a beneficiary of
the shift from offline to online as it
relates to e-commerce
but they also benefited from the
structural increase in pet ownership
but chewy success wasn't just timing
analysts say it had a lot to do with how
management at the company
handled the demand from the pandemic pet
boom when covid19 first took hold in the
u.s
in march 2020 chewie like many other
companies
was overwhelmed with orders the surge in
e-commerce demand
strained postal services and this caused
week-long delays that put even more
pressure on retailers
sumit singh the ceo of chewie explains
how this
impacted his company when industry-wide
supply chains were disrupted what was
going on was that we weren't receiving
products optimally across the
fulfillment center
number two because fulfillment center
backlog was so high
typically we deliver product between one
and two days to customers reliably
our shipping times went up to seven to
ten days competitors like amazon
face similar issues but at this key
moment
chewie made strategic decisions to
handle the increase in demand
it hired thousands of new workers while
protecting shipments for its core
subscription customers
the company also invested in shipping
packages by air to ensure timely
delivery
across a combination of these three
mechanisms we were able to sort of
control our situation
while these investments were expensive
shanks says they were the right move
for businesses that can retain these
customers which we think chewy can
this should ultimately pay off dividends
over the course of the next several
years
over the past year chewie rolled out a
number of new products
with a focus on pet health in october
the company released its own pet
telehealth service called
connect with a vet the company's ceo
says the platform was launched in
response to the demand for vet care
while clinics were impacted by global
shutdowns we internally said okay
how about we develop a solution that
allows us to connect customers and
veterinarians
in a time of crisis and we did exactly
that chewy continued to lean into its
healthcare business
the company announced that it would be
manufacturing its own compounded
medications
which analysts say is a competitive
advantage but rolling out new products
is expensive
and this cut into chewy's profits
analysts say these product investments
along with other pandemic related
expenses are part of why the company has
yet to show an annual profit
anytime you make an investment uh yes
you're committing to
uh you know generating a healthy return
over the long term and we are very
long-term focused
as it incidentally happens this
particular service connect with a vet
yes it is currently a cost center
because we're not monetizing it it's
free
for customers still analysts say some
investors have concerns
one of the things that investors have
also been a little bit concerned about
is the fact that chewy's flow through
has been smaller or lighter than some
other e-commerce retailers experienced
during the pandemic and i think part of
that reason was
the incremental cleaning costs and the
shipping costs but also the fact that
they did open a new distribution center
the company's stock saw pullback over
recent weeks
the cost that we've invested in our
health in the health and safety of our
team members
we are not looking to roll those costs
back uh you know up
100 we believe 80 of those costs will
actually remain in network in 2021. once
inventory shortages
are more or inventory balances are
better in check and control
we believe that logistics costs and
inventory freight fulfillment cost and
all of that stuff
will actually start becoming uh you know
a little less of a concern
despite challenges during the pandemic
analysts say the future of the company
looks positive
on march 30th chewie reported its first
quarterly net profit ever
along with a 47 increase in sales over
the past year
analysts expect chewy to have its first
full year of profitability in 2021
but they say that its rate of growth
will likely slow down
this was a major structural shift in
e-commerce penetration that is
we think unlikely to revert so we do
think 2021 e-commerce growth decelerates
versus what we saw in 2020
but we don't think you actually give
back any of the share shift so we do
think this is
structural this is permanent experts say
the growth
e-commerce companies like chewie have
experienced are likely to be the most
significant and lasting effects of the
pandemic on the pet care industry